the ball is firmly in russia's court
while we're determined to accelerate
these efforts we do save from a position
of strengths we are combining dialogue
with deterrence and that's why the prime
minister is considering options for
further deployments of our armed forces
to reassure and protect allies on nato's
eastern flank
we're preparing to offer to support nato
with additional fast jets warships and
military specialists
as nato's biggest spender in europe on
defense we are prepared to deploy our
forces accordingly as to act
we will be laying legislation before the
house that will significantly strengthen
our hand in dealing with russia's
aggressive action towards ukraine it
will go further than ever before
until now the uk has only been able to
sanction those linked to destabilization
of ukraine
this new legislation will give us the
power to sanction a much broader range
of individuals and businesses
we will be able to target any company
that is linked to the russian state
engages in business of economic
significance to the russian state or
operates in a sector of strategic
significance to the russian state
not only will we will be able to target
these entities we will also be able to
go after those who own or control them
this will be the toughest sanction
regime against russia we have ever had
and it is the most radical departure and
approach since leaving the european
union
those in and around the kremlin will
have nowhere to hide
we will make sure
that those who share responsibility
for the kremlin's aggressive and
destabilizing action
will share in bearing a heavy cost
their assets in the uk will be frozen
no uk business or individual would be
able to transact with them
and should they seek to the enter the uk
they would be turned back